my father once told me a story a story
that I've never been able to forget for
a few reasons I think it's the first
story he ever told me as a child it's
also the story of how my grandfather
died but honestly that isn't the reason
you hear stories on TV or sometimes you
overhear something in a public place
people talk about ghosts and aliens and
you think to yourself that ain't real
they're making it up or they're mistaken
perhaps they're even crazy or something
like that you just can't believe
anything they're saying that is until
something happens something that brings
it all together connects the dots in a
way that you didn't think of before
maybe it happens to you or maybe you
hear the same story again and again
happenin to different people it doesn't
take long before the world becomes a lot
bigger than you thought it was as I said
this is a story my father told me but I
never believed him even though he swore
up and down that it was true it wasn't
until I started clicking around the
internet that I started to believe I
started to his stories just like the one
my father told me it didn't take long
before I began to believe in the rake
that's not what my father called of
course he's never used the Internet in
his life he wouldn't know that that's
what the consensus named it when he
chose to call it anything other than it
or that thing he called it skinwalker
Arthur an old Cherokee tale his
grandfather told him but I'll tell you
the story the way he told it to me we
were out hunting one night he told me
coyotes would kill him for 50 bucks of
skin at that point they lived on a dairy
farm in Ohio they'd also kill carve
sometimes we do it every night because
we needed the money
sometimes while we were out to eat come
across a deer and kill that too our
landlord didn't mind and it could feed
our family for a few nights and save us
some money anyway we were done making
the rounds and began to head home
walking because we didn't have a car
back then or some four-wheeler we cut
through the woods and that's when we
came upon it blood everywhere splattered
on the trees in the grass in the creek
everywhere at first we figured it was a
pack of coyotes we'd seen it sometimes
they can't scavenge and they start
hunting deer or cattle the worst was an
ill-bred with feral dogs but it wasn't
like that see on a pack of dogs or
wolves or even coyotes attack something
they do it right they'll pick one of its
weak or sick or old or just small
they'll hunt it they'll draw it into a
corner someplace it can't get out of and
then they'll run it to the biggest one
the Alpha that they will never see the
Alpha coming it might hear it but it
will never see it it'll just notice that
it's throats gone and then drop dead
it's quick it's clean but that wasn't
what happened here something had run up
on a den of deer coyotes won't attack a
den neither will walls because there's
too much of a fight there was three I
think three bodies just torn apart you'd
see a head here a leg here torso there
predators don't do that they don't leave
behind scraps whatever had done this
hadn't done it for food but for fun of
course at the time we were unaware we
saw a bunch of carcasses and we thought
it was something we could take care of I
remember my dad telling me to go home he
thought it was a pack of feral dogs but
I wasn't leaving him and I damn sure
wasn't walking through two miles of
woods alone with nothing but a 22 and a
pocketknife he was only 13 at the time
so a 22 rifle was about the only gun he
could reliably use dad had a shotgun and
I wasn't going anywhere without him it
took me a while to convince him but
finally we began track him whatever had
left the carcasses behind and it wasn't
hard either we just followed the blood
either that thing had bled a deer before
it got away or a dragged one for a mile
I don't know but what I do know is that
I had never seen my father scared before
that night we started hearing noises
I've been in a lot of woods in my life
I've been all over the world but I've
never heard noises similar to the ones I
did that night I heard things screaming
I heard deer and foxes rabbits raccoons
and birds all of them just scared keep
in mind this must have been around 12:00
or 1:00 o'clock
except for foxes in some birds nothing
was supposed to even be awake but they
weren't just awake they were moving I
saw flocks of birds that night to fly
straight into trees just trying to get
out of there
we eventually came across a pack of
coyotes nearly shot a couple of them
thinking it's what we were looking for
but then we saw they were running
towards us and they ran right past us
didn't even notice us then some deer did
the same some rabbits squirrels foxes
and even a couple of wild hogs these
things were supposed to be eating each
other and the only thing they cared
about was getting the hell out of there
we should have put it together quicker
that maybe whatever we were tracking it
wasn't something we were supposed to see
and it wasn't something we could kill I
don't know why we didn't just go home I
guess we were curious I think that was
my dad's nature to go towards trouble to
fight and knowing what I knew about what
my father did during the war my nature
was to stay close to him we finally got
into an open Valley it was normally a
soy field but it wasn't in season so it
was nothing more than just flat dirt we
saw the tracks a lot of animals fleeing
the forest that paved over the land but
where the deer bud was nothing had taken
a single step like they were leaving it
for us to find the tracks was shallow
whatever it was couldn't have weighed
more than a hundred pounds but that
didn't mean much
a bobcat weighing around 40 pounds once
nearly tore out my throat all that means
is that it's quick and much definitely
hard to hit so we continued to follow
the tracks and it didn't take us long to
find who it was there's this old school
that sits on top of a hill half of it
had been ripped out by tornado but
nobody lived there not for a long time
we caught homeless people in there
sometimes or druggies looking for a safe
place to shoot up we figured that maybe
that was it maybe it was some kind of
sick kid right in a high but we didn't
think that for long we get within 50
yards and we hear this noise a
screeching kind of sound
those sort of made up of two different
sounds one was a high-pitched screech
and the other was a low-pitched growl it
was making them both at the same time we
get within 20 yards when we hear the
same sound I can remember thinking and
it sounded like paper being torn apart
with someone swinging water in a bucket
back and forth dad looks at me and
kneels down he whispers I have to stay
behind him because we're about to corner
him any animal will fight when it's
cornered especially if it's a predator
but we can tell by the tracks that is
just one he tells me it's probably a
single feral dog most likely rabid the
plan is to sneak up on it when it's
eating shoot it and then keep shooting
it until it don't move no more then slit
its throat and if he gets to dead then
it's my job to shoot or stab it to get
it off him he begins to walk up and I'm
right behind him a tad to his side I can
see what it is it was leaning over a
carcass tearing off its flesh and
throwing whatever it didn't nibble a
sight there was blood all over the brick
glistening in the moonlight
it was pale white human looking but not
quite human it had arms and legs like a
human but it's at like a monkey hunched
over and his hands weren't normal it had
long fingers with claws at the end after
seeing it my dad began to hesitate he
wasn't about to fire in a person so he
cleared his throat and tried to get it
to turn around I swear to God all the
noise just ceased I ain't never heard
true silence before and I never did
after that but for two seconds
nothing nothing made any noise which
made it even louder when it turned
around it made this shrill cry and
jumped on my dad he fired a shot but I
think he missed if he hit the thing and
it certainly didn't care but it was on
him Taron parts of him off I started
shooting with the 22 point-blank but it
barely even bled the thing I got a 5
rounds and then I starting hitting it
with the gun but but it wasn't budging
it didn't even register that I was there
and then it began coronet my dad
taking off bits of his flesh it started
on his torso ripping off the skin I
could barely recognize him it tore off
his throat it tore off his nose its eyes
its counted him and then it really
started digging in it ripped off the
bottom half of his jaw the little bones
in the troop of your neck and then his
ribs but somehow my dad's knife ended up
in the thing shoulder and my dad was now
on its back I began to run and by god
I'm running faster than I've ever run
before it was following me I ended up
back in the woods opposite to the ones
we had been in and I'm heading towards
my landlords house it was only about
half a mile away
I can hear this thing screeching and
moaning I hear tree branches crack and
get thrown around it's like someone's
taken the axe to every tree I pass it's
cracking so loud and often but I just
ain't looking back finally I tripped
into some gravel I look up and there's
my landlord and a bunch of his body he's
drinking around a campfire I scream and
I cry and they come over I'm telling
them to call an ambulance and he looks
at me and I'll never forget what he said
what is that on your back he asked me
just as he said it he saw one of those
god-awful flannel shirts my dad wore
everywhere it was the only thing that
was left of my dad most of his head
torso and waist was all gone suddenly we
hear it screeching my landlord grabs me
and my dad gets thrown to the ground and
fighting him crying because I still
think we can save him somehow but my dad
was gone he picked me up and brought him
inside with him he and his buddies were
all inside locking the doors and get in
their guns
the landlord asked me what happened but
I just don't know what to tell him he
peaced enough of it together to
understand that there was something
dangerous out there
all the lights in the house are on
someone called the cops they'll be here
but in 15 minutes we look outside and we
see it walk in front of the fire they
made I still can't tell what it is but
one of them says it looks like an ape
suddenly something goes through the
window
and we fire but when we take a second
look we see it's my landlords dog
just the body though not its head
towards legs we start pushing things in
front of the doors in the windows when
we hear something in the garage I
remember one of my friends saying the
door was open we hear metal and glass
just being ripped apart we put a couch
in a TV in front of the door to the
garage hoping it would hold it banged
around some more but then it got quiet
not silent like it was before we could
still hear things move around the guys
were talking making sure that their guns
were ready and someone handed me a
pistol no sooner than I cocked back the
hammer we hear something shatter
upstairs then we heard it screech again
except this time it was louder
it didn't echo or fade because it was
inside we were rushed in a one door
leading upstairs and we got to it just
as that thing did it opened it just a
bit and four or five men slammed into it
he got its hand caught in the door
someone with a shotgun took care of that
put the barrel right up against his
wrist and pulled the trigger cut its
hand straight off that only pissed it
off though it started pushing on the
door
chlorine we were on one side pushing
back as best we could and it was on the
other doing the same the wood just
wasn't gonna hold
so someone tells us to keep our heads
down suddenly the top half of the door
is just gone my ears are ringing and
there are splinters everywhere two or
three of them just unloaded on the top
half of the door I don't really know
where it went after that the police got
here but I was still glued to the door
the Sun was up before they managed to
get me away from it they put me in the
hospital for a while a lot of people
talked to me but I didn't talk back when
I got back home I got a job working for
the landlord on his farm we didn't talk
much not about that thing anyway but I
signed up for the Army when I was 19 and
he sat me down with a drink of scotch as
a send-off I asked him right away what
the police told him the story they went
with was a wild animal probably a wolf
or maybe a bear that had migrated north
I asked him how they could say that when
they had the hand he looked at me
stunned he tells me that the hand never
made it back to the station the cop that
was carrying the hand had a car wreck
driving into a tree and dying on impact
the hand was never found probably taken
away by another animal when the cops
finally acknowledged that the hand even
existed they said it was simply the pour
of a bear that looked like a human hand
I never talked to the landlord again he
went miss him when I was in basic
training they never found him they said
he owed people some money and just ran
away but I don't think it was that
simple I never went back to those woods
I wouldn't even if I had the whole US
Army at my back but that was a lie when
my mother died I don't think my father
thought he had anything left and he
might as well go back and settle old
scores
he went to those woods but he never came
back
the FBI was called and they did a show
for everyone involved
but I knew that they weren't really
looking I had to get one drunk and slip
him a few 50's before he finally told me
they'd get a few calls every year about
those woods about someone just up in and
vanishing but that was what he wanted to
tell me before he got up and left with
the rest of his team he wrote something
on a napkin the rake I didn't know what
it meant until I searched it on the
Internet honestly I would have rather
not known
[Music]